propose un jeu si tu veux je dois
essayer de deviner ce que tu penses
d'accord on essaie vous ne voyez jamais
son visage normal patrick poivey est la
voix française de bruce willis un vrai
travail de comédien dans un film comme
le sixième sens par exemple le doublage
se fait séquence par séquence et le tout
peut durer jusqu'à 15 jours il y à la
voie le temps et la nécessité de rester
fidèle au personnage est avant tout
appareil de comedia c'est surtout pas un
autre travail c'est à dire qu'il ya
quelqu'un à l'écran qu'à une intention
et vous vous devez restituer la réalité
de la pension qu'il a au moment où il le
fait que ce qui compte c'est l'acteur
qui est l écran le doublage c'est qu'un
ersatz c'est
on s'approche et éventuellement de ski
adam l'original mais on la bible
l'original on peut pas le doublage
parfait ce serait celui qui sera
l'équivalent de l'original c'est tout
avec également toujours la nécessité de
ne pas mélanger les deux personnes ne
dit pas ça patrick poivre et bonjour
bruxelles énerve pas ce qu'il veut
rester lui même pas moyen de le faire
sortir de son rôle d'amy moore ça va
bien et il paraît que ça va mal chez eux
ouais enfin bon c'est le ruisseau
domaine privée harris des merdes
[Musique]